Thank you for inviting me.
It's a thrill to be here, uh,
on the Cambridge campus of Google.
And as I'm sure all of you well know,
we are for the past year and a half,
we've been in a sort of renewed discussion
of inclusion of women in the tech
sector, the experience of
women in the tech sector.
This is a conversation that
we periodically seem to
have and I'm here to remind
you that women helped create
and found the tech sector, uh,
so much of which was created and
pioneered during World War II.
My book code girls is
not about coding so much.
It is as it is about code
breaking during World War Two,
our code breaking force was actually
larger than the British force at,
at, at Bletchley Park. And more
than half of it was female. Uh,
and this is an untold story.
I think of it as a mash up of
the imitation game. And uh,
and the greatest generation
actually because these women
were the hidden figures
of the greatest generation.
So a mash up of all three of those.
And I like to start my
talks with this slide,
which sort of depicts the plight
of the educated woman in 1942.
Uh,
this shows the May court at Goucher
college in the spring of 1942,
uh, uh, may court as far as I could tell,
it was a very common thing for
colleges to have at the time.
It was sort of a vestige,
I think,
of a pagan fertility ritual in
which a young female colleagues,
seniors are dressed in virginal white and,
and symbolically ushered
into the marriage market.
And Galcher college at that time
was a what, what were they called?
Girls School. Uh, the women who went
there were called Galcher girls.
It was an all female college
in Urban Baltimore, Maryland.
It's now coeducational in suburban Talson.
But at the time it was all female.
It had been founded like
most women's colleges, uh,
in the late 19th century at a time when
people generally believed that higher
education was not only
unnecessary for women,
but not necessarily good for women,
uh,
that it sort of made women overeducated
obnoxious, difficult to live with.
There was actually a Harvard physician.
This is no kidding,
who argued that higher education made
women in fertile because it swelled their
brains at the expense of
their wounds. Uh, and,
and people accepted that or some
version of that viewpoint about the
pointlessness really of giving
women too much education.
And so schools like Galcher and
the seven sisters schools, uh,
many of which are here in Massachusetts
were founded to tilt against that
viewpoint to show that women
deserved an education, uh, and that,
that women could, could succeed in
a difficult learning environment.
So these were very academically,
uh,
academically ambitious schools that were
founded to educate young women and the
women on this platform,
we're,
we're more unusual than they would even
have realized in the sense that at this
time,
only 4% of American women achieved
a four year college degree.
And one reason for that was because
of this attitude that you know,
that it wasn't necessarily good for women
to become overeducated. And of course,
because so many campuses in that day,
we're still close to women.
The Ivy League was largely closed
to women. My home state of Virginia,
the University of Virginia actually held
out for as long as it could and to the
late 1960s before it would award
a full four year degree to women.
And so there were many campuses
that were closed to women. Uh,
and there were many families particularly
coming out of the depression that were
reluctant to pay the tuition for a girl
to go to college because even if a young
woman was very motivated and did very
well in terms of jobs that were available
after graduation,
really the only job a woman could
count on upon graduating from a fine
institution was teaching school.
And that's great if you
want to be a school teacher,
but if you want to be an engineer or an
architect or a lawyer or a physician,
if you're a woman, you would largely
be shut out of those graduate schools.
And those business at works.
So many families would do the calculation
and conclude that it wasn't worthwhile,
uh,
to educate a daughter.
But one reason that a family might decide
to send a girl to a girls school like
voucher would be so she could get the
proverbial Mrs degree so that she could
date and hopefully marry a young man
attending a neighboring men school.
Like in this case, Johns Hopkins
or Annapolis, the Naval Academy,
which was 20 miles away, uh,
from, from Galcher. And so many,
I've interviewed many of the young
women on this platform and a,
or some of them at least, uh, and, uh,
they recall a lot of dating and also
enormous pressure to get married.
And so they experienced sort of the twin
pressures back then of wanting to do
well and prove that women deserve to
be educated, but knowing that they,
that they were under a lot of
pressure to get married by graduation.
And so just to show you,
for example,
how strong this pressure was at
Wellesley College in Massachusets,
the yearbook in the class of 42 actually
had a section naming all of the young
women who were engaged to be married and
who they were engaged to be married to,
as well as names of women who had left
before graduation in order to get married
and who they had married. So that's how
intense the pressure was to get married.
That's why they had rituals like the May
court to symbolize that they were being
ushered into the marriage market.
Wellesley at the time had something
called the senior class hoop role,
and the lore around the hoop role was
that the winner of that would be the
classes first bride.
What I love about this particular photo
though is it shows how the world was
changing and how the trajectory of
these women's lives was about to change
enormously. So if you look at this
young woman where the cursor is,
her name was Jacqueline Jenkins.
Uh,
later on after she married, after the
war, her married name would be Jenkins,
NY mother,
a Bill Nye.
The science guy so you can get a
sense of her intellectual chops.
And this was her good friend Gwyneth
commender and these two young women had
already been secretly tapped by
the u s navy to learn how to become
codebreakers.
Uh,
so they were being ushered into an arcane
field that nobody in the United States
would, would have heard
of at that time. Um,
code making and code breaking.
As you may know,
many people in this room might have
indulged him that some point in your lives
are now.
It's an impulse that goes back really
to the beginning of human communication.
As long as we've been
able to write and speak,
we have at some point had the urge to
communicate secretly with somebody using a
code or cipher that nobody else can break.
And if you don't believe
that this is true,
when I speak to elementary school
audiences and I asked those kids how many
people in that classroom
have made a secret code or
safer at some point in their
lives, every hand goes up because
it's, it's also a, you know,
a really universal impulse that children
feel to communicate without adults
being able to listen in.
So Julius Caesar had a cipher,
you might've heard of it, he
moved that they moved, uh,
you would move a letter for four spaces
ahead and the alphabet and substitute
that letter that's called a
substitution cipher. As you may know,
the mark of a good code and cipher is
that ease of use between the people who
know the system and unbreak ability
for by the rest of the world.
So the site, the cipher that Caesar
used would satisfy the ease of use,
but not the, not the unbreak ability.
Uh, in terms of the rest of the world.
That's pretty easy cipher
a actually to break.
So these young women were being ushered
into a field that has existed since the
dawn of communication that
was very familiar in Europe
for centuries before this
time.
Uh,
because of diplomatic intrigue because
of wars between European countries, uh,
and kingdoms.
But in the United States we were more
naive about what we'd called listening in
or reading other gentleman's male. Uh, we
were reluctant before the war to do it,
but we were having to learn
to do it pretty quickly. Uh,
and so these young women,
these two young women,
along with about a dozen of their guts,
your classmates were being
secretly trained in a locked
classroom at the top of
Galcher Hall,
taught by a naval officer as well as
an English professor named Ola Winslow.
Nobody on this platform knew that they
were being prepared for a completely
different future than the one
that had been envisioned for them.
Their families didn't know, their
brothers didn't know their boyfriends,
didn't know,
their roommates,
didn't know that they were secretly
training to become naval code breakers.
And the reason that those young women
had been tapped to learn how to do this
work of course was
because on December 7th,
1941 we were attacked at Pearl Harbor.
It was a surprise attack.
Our fleet was anchored in Pearl Harbor
that the judge is the goal of the
Japanese was to destroy our Pacific
fleet and to drive us to our knees.
It had the opposite effect. Of course,
it galvanized the American public.
Every young man wanted to sign up
to fight. Uh, and so it was well.
So the attack at Pearl Harbor was the
galvanizing event that propelled us into
World War II.
We declare war on Japan the next day,
Germany declares war on us several days
later and all of a sudden we were in
what was called at the
time, total war, global war.
All of a sudden men are shipping out on
aircraft carriers and the Pacific Ocean
on convoys going across the Atlantic
Ocean to Europe and to North Africa.
And so we are suddenly at war at exactly
the time when we understand just how
unprepared we are in terms of our
intelligence gathering abilities.
Because the other thing
that Pearl Harbor was,
was a massive intelligence failure.
So I'm from the Washington DC area.
We take for granted that we have 17
intelligence agencies in Washington now.
We had none of that at the
beginning of World War Two.
When we are suddenly sending so many
young American men into harm's way,
we have been reminded or we have been
sort of woken up to, uh, the, the,
our inability to anticipate
what the enemy is going to do.
A Pearl Harbor was a terrible surprise,
particularly to the u s military,
particularly to the u s navy and
heads are gonna roll as a result of,
of that terrible surprise.
And so what will happen in Washington
DC is that we will start to very try to
quickly build up our
intelligence gathering operation.
The office of strategic services will be
formed, our first release spy network,
which will become the CIA.
But it takes time to build a spine
that work in, in foreign countries.
And what we could learn how to do much
more quickly was intercept enemy signals
and learn how to break
the enemy code systems.
So if you've seen the imitation game,
you're familiar with at least
one of these code system,
which is the cipher that's being
generated by the enigma machine that the
Germans are using.
All of the German military services
are particularly the u boats we are
concerned about. Admiral Donitz is
communicating with every u boat, uh,
using enciphered communications that
have been scrambled by the enigma machine
that is in every u boat.
Uh,
and so that's just an example of one
system that's being used during the war.
And just to give you a sense of how many
enciphered and encoded systems are now
racing through the airwaves,
if you think of how many communications
you send through the air every day,
write emails, tweets,
Instagrams, Facebook updates,
everything that you send all day long, you
might be sending them. Now, if you are,
it's fine. But you can imagine, you know,
if you individually are
sending this many messages,
think about during World War Two,
this farflung war in which enemy
commanders and, uh, are, are,
are to communicate over
thousands of miles, right?
With the people that they command.
Emerald.
Donna is communicating with every u boat.
Some of the u boats are thousands of,
you know, hundred thousand
miles away from his command.
And so all of these enciphered and encoded
communication systems are traveling
through the airwaves,
radio waves.
They are being encoded at enciphered
sent generally using Morse code.
And that is what we have to learn how to
snatch out of the airwaves and decipher
in order that there not be another Pearl
Harbor attack as we are sending our
young men into harm's way.
So the u s Navy knows that it has to
ramp up practically overnight. It has to,
as we would say today, scale up.
It's code breaking force, uh,
practically overnight.
And it has to do this at
exactly the moment when the
young men it would normally
recruit to learn how to do this work
are suddenly unavailable because they're
fighting.
Uh,
and so the navy before World War Two
had a very small code breaking bureau.
It was not a prestigious
occupation in the U s navy.
You can imagine if you're
a career naval officer,
you want to be commanding a ship.
You want to be out there on the ocean.
So there was a very small code breaking
force and there were monthly memos that
were generated to say,
where are they were getting the,
the sort of minds that they needed in
order to learn how to do this work. Uh,
so this was when I was doing my
research at the national archives.
I looked through these, these monthly
memos. And normally before the war,
the navy would have turned to MIT.
It would have turned to Harvard.
It would turn to places of the Ivy
League to find the young men who were
trainable to do this work.
And you can see in this memo,
the light bulb moment going on over some
naval bureaucrats head since the young
men are unavailable to us. Let's see
what these educated young women can do.
So you see,
I've circled new source women's colleges.
The light bulb moment goes on.
Let us try these educated and trained
young women who have been at these great
schools, they've had Latin, they've
had Greek, they've had physics,
they've had math, they've
had English. Uh, you know,
they had this really great liberal arts
education. Uh, so let's see if they can,
if they can serve the nation.
Uh,
and so young women at Galcher as well
as all of the seven sisters colleges,
Wellesley, Smith, Radcliffe, Bryn Mawr,
young women would be secretly identified
by their math and astronomy professors.
They were being invited in one
by one to secret conferences.
It was like the Harry Potter a moment
for these young women when you get the
letter a, and so they would be invited
in, they would be asked two questions,
do you like crossword puzzles and
are you engaged to be married?
And if they answered yes to
the first and no to the second,
and they would be invited to take a
secret correspondence course that the u s
navy had developed to train.
It's cryptographers to train.
It's it's crypt analysts
and code breakers. And they
would come to Washington DC,
this first cohort of women who would
train all during their senior year at the
same time that they were doing all the
academic work they needed to graduate.
They would come to Washington at exactly
the moment when we understand in a
major way how important code breaking is
going to be to the outcome of this war.
And keep in mind that in 1942 it was not
for day that we were going to win World
War II, that the allies were going to
win World War II. It looked very bleak,
right? All of Europe now is
occupied or as an access country,
Japan is a very,
very formidable foe in the Pacific.
So we do not anticipate that we're
going to win this war. It's a very,
very scary moment. And so the women
after they graduate in the June,
June of 1942 or their exhorted by the u
s navy to come to Washington as soon as
they can,
there are so many of them that they're
sitting on upturned wastebaskets in the
very crowded central naval facility and
in June of 42 if you've heard of any
battle in World War II and he see battle,
you've probably heard of the battle of
midway and that was a very important
battle in the Pacific that turned on
our ability to break the Japanese naval
fleet code.
And the reason that we knew how that fleet
code worked was because a woman named
Agnes Driscoll and math and music teacher
from Texas had been a civilian working
in the navy's Code Breaking Bureau and
she had diagnosed that the Japanese naval
fleet code consistent of five digit
code groups might stand for let's say
destroyer a five digits and then they
would add to insight for that code group.
They would add five digits to that
code group two and cipher each digit,
right, to change each digit using
something called non-caring edition. I,
Mr Shell had spent the 1930s figuring
out how the Japanese system worked.
The reason that we weren't able to read
those messages right before a Pearl
Harbor was because the Japanese had
changed their code books as they did
periodically.
And then we would have to start all over
again figuring out what the code group
stood for.
But we were back in by June of 1942 the
Japanese had set out to an bushes on the
island of midway and finish off our
Pacific fleet. We read those messages,
we were waiting to
ambush the end butchers.
We defeated the Japanese and the three
days see battle that's now one of the
most famous see battles of all time.
And all of a sudden it's understood that
code breaking is no longer an obscure
unpressed aegis occupation.
It's going to be central to
victory in both theaters of war.
And so the women are pouring into
Washington at exactly the moment when we
understand how important
their work is going to be. So,
just to give you a sense of the division
of Labor, when we enter the war,
if you've seen the imitation game,
you know that the British
thanks to Alan Turing and,
and a large code breaking force have
diagnosed how the German enigma system
works.
So the,
the British are going to be the lead
code breakers for the Atlantic Ocean and
the European theater
at least at the outset.
But we're going to be a junior partner
working with them because we are now at
risk, right? We're sending all
these young men across the Atlantic.
The convoys are being terribly
menaced by the wolf packs, uh,
that the u boats were sinking
our convoys. Uh, but, but the,
we're going to let the British take
the lead on that, at least at first.
But we have lead code
breaking responsibility for
the massive Pacific Ocean
where we have just been terribly
surprised not that long ago.
And so the u s navy is going to be
primarily responsible for breaking the
Japanese naval fleet code. So that's
what those young women are going to do.
But meanwhile,
our US army has responsibility for a
completely different set of codes and
ciphers being used by the Japanese army,
which is now spread out on all these
islands around the Pacific. Right?
The Japanese were taking the Philippines,
they've taken Guam,
they've taken wake island,
they've taken the Malayan peninsula,
they've taken all of these land masses
and the Japanese army is communicating
back with Tokyo.
And so our US army is ultimately going
to need thousands of codebreakers to
break these systems and
it also needs women.
And so World War Two is this wonderful,
terrible moment where there
is unparalleled competition
for the first time for
smart educated women to
show what they can do.
So the private sector is going
to start a competing for women.
Mit is going to start taking women into
its graduate programs to run it's analog
computers and the US Navy and the u s
army are going to start a hot competition
for educated women. Uh, when
I was doing my research,
I found memos in which the navy was
pissed off because the army got to Wheaton
College or Connecticut College before
it got there. Uh, and it argued that,
that the army was poaching
it's girls. So, um,
so when the U s army had to figure out
where it's going to get it's educated
women, it decides to turn to
teacher's colleges as well.
These are humbler institution where
women are being trained to become school
teachers. Uh, so I'll just show you, cause
you'll hear from her at the very end.
Dorothy Ramallah Lee was training to be
a math teacher at Indiana state teachers
college in Pennsylvania.
Uh,
to be a math teacher was a high
aspiration for a woman because a lot of
departments wouldn't hire women as math
professors. This is my central character.
Dot. Braden. She's still alive.
She'll be 99 this June. Uh,
so back in 1942, she was a school
teacher in Chatham, Virginia.
And what I love about the
army's recruiting strategy,
which is different from the navy's,
the army decided that that recruiting,
so we went and secretly a teacher's
colleges wouldn't be enough for its needs.
So it decided to massively
recruit in public,
trying to get women to sign up to
do secret war work in Washington.
So he decided to recruit school
teachers, actual school teachers, young,
overworked,
underpaid young women who by definition
were single because in almost any
occupation at the time,
if you are a woman that you got married,
you were expected to quit and stay home.
And that was certainly
true of school teachers.
So these women were the ideal workers.
That's the way we would think of them
today. Underpaid, overworked, single.
They could work full time,
could work in the middle of the night,
which they would be called upon to do.
And the army strategy to recruit these
women, west ascendance, handsomest,
young army officers out to lurk
and post offices and hotels.
Initially it was confined to the southern
states, Joe particular bureaucratic,
a division because it
was recruiting civilians.
And so the thinking on the part of the
army was that these young women would be
induced to sign up,
would be lured to Washington,
hoping that they would make a marriage
to a handsome young man like the officer
who was recruiting them.
And what I love about.is she shows
how wrong headed this strategy was.
In fact, in 1942. Dot.
Was a graduate of Randolph
Macon Women's College,
which was a fine woman's college
in, in downtown Lynchburg, Virginia,
which is where she grew up. She was the
oldest daughter and a family of four.
Her mother was supporting the whole family
as a secretary at a uniform factory.
Um, her parents were separated.
Her mom was supporting the family.
Dot was now working as a school teacher.
Uh,
her income was very important
to the family upkeep.
She had two younger brothers who were
now in the fighting like every young
American woman. She wanted to do
her part to bring the boys home.
She also wanted to get out
of a marriage that she, uh,
had been sort of pressured into entering
into her college boyfriend had sent her
a ring and engagement ring from
training camp in California.
She didn't want to marry him.
She liked him,
but she didn't want to spend the
rest of her life with him. Uh, and,
but she didn't know how to get out of it
because women at the time were told to
not upset the morale of the troops.
That was a big deal.
Women were entrusted with the morale of,
of the fighting force,
and so she didn't feel like
she could send the ring back.
But the chance to go to Washington
and do unspecified secret war work,
uh,
was it was a way to get out of a marriage.
She wouldn't have to follow
him to training camp in
California the way that he
was pressuring her.
So I just love the fact
that the recruiting strategy
was exactly wrong headed,
even as she was very inclined
to take this job, uh,
to sign on the dotted line
and come to Washington.
Her other motivation was to
come to Washington. Lynchburg,
Virginia is three hours
away from Washington DC.
She had never been to
the nation's capitol.
She grew up there during the depression.
Her family didn't have a car.
She had never seen the big city.
And Washington now is really the beating
heart of the free world along with
London, England. You know, it's
the major capital free city.
So much of Europe is occupied now.
It would really become the heart of the
allied war effort and the chance to come
to Washington and serve that effort was
an enormous opportunity for her to help
bring her brother's home and also to,
um,
to make twice as much money as she could.
As a school teacher.
She was making $900 a year
teaching in school in Chatham.
She would make $1,600 a year
working as a code breaker.
So in the fall of 1943,
she found herself on union station.
She took a cab to a place called
Arlington Hall before the war.
It had been at what with what
they call it, a junior college,
which was a thing back then again when
it was thought that it was best not to
give women too much education.
A junior college was a place
where a family could send,
it's a daughter to board.
She could get high school classes as well
as a couple of years of maybe college
English and French as well as sort of
typing and horseback riding and deportment
and the kind of skills that were thought
for a um, you know, sort of right for uh,
an upscale young woman. Uh, the,
the u s military needed secure facilities
for its massive code breaking forces.
So it kicked those girls out
of Burlington Hall in mood.
The code breakers in built
a temporary buildings.
You can see here the school
teachers now being trained here,
they're learning the geography of
Asia. You can see them intercept, uh,
receiving intercepted
messages from the Pacific.
And you can see how big these rooms were.
A former school teachers are coming
now to work for the war effort.
And what dots still has a hard time
getting her mind around is that she became
part of one of the three most important
code breaking successes of World War II.
And she didn't even understand the
importance of the work that she was doing.
So two of them you've already heard of.
Art Breaking of the German enigma cipher
was one of the most important code
breaking triumphs.
We've heard of that because of the
imitation game and because of places like
Bletchley Park that exists now is museums.
Uh,
the battle of midway and are breaking
of the Japanese naval fleet code was
number two.
But number three,
which you don't hear as much about was
our braking of the end super enciphered
system being used by the Japanese army
to communicate with its supply ships.
So the Japanese army spread out on
these islands around the Pacific,
everything that's brought to them,
food,
fuel re reinforcement troops,
a replacement parts for aircraft.
It all has to be brought by ship.
These are formal commercial ships that
had been now commandeered by the Japanese
army. They're called Morrow's. Uh,
they are traveling around the
Pacific and other bodies of water.
They're communicating with their
central command, what they're carrying,
where they're headed for.
We're intercepting all of those messages
there are being sent back to the school
teachers.
So it's 242 school teachers including dot.
Braden who are breaking those messages
systems as fast as they could. Dot.
Remembers running to
the overlap or station,
which was the next station of what
was basically an assembly line.
The women would break the message as
fast as they could so that the contents
could be radio to an American submarine
commander who would be waiting on the
horizon when the supply ship appeared
as a result of how fast and well the
school teachers worked and how well
the submarine commanders did their job.
We sang thousands and thousands of supply
ships to the point where most Japanese
army desk where the results of starvation
and disease because they weren't
getting the supplies that they needed.
So that's how important the
messages were that dot was breaking.
Again,
these,
these slides just give you a sense of
how massive the eye of the operation was.
I'll just talk very quickly about one
more system to give you a sense of how
many systems there were.
Uh, this group of women,
we're breaking the cipher system
being used by Japanese diplomats.
They were using machine
that we called purple, uh,
to scramble the romanized letters of,
of a Japanese transmission.
So this might seem counterintuitive,
but Japanese diplomats are
stationed in Europe, right?
They're stationed in Germany. They're in
Vichy, France, they're in occupied France,
they're in Italy. They're,
they're all over Europe.
They're communicated with Hitler and with,
and with,
with muscle Lania and with all of the
access leaders and they're reporting it
all back to Tokyo in very, very
detailed, wordy, diplomatic messages.
We were reading every single
one of those messages.
Thanks to a woman named Genevieve Gracen,
a graduate of the University of Buffalo,
who before the war had the key insight
that enabled us to break that machine
generated cipher.
She had been unable to find any university
willing to hire a female math teacher.
So she had been hired by the army's very
small prewar code breaking bureau and
had the central insight that announced
that allowed us to break that machine
cipher. And just to give you a sense
of how valuable this intelligence was,
when the Japanese diplomats were
invited to tour the coast of France,
they were invited to see
Hitler's at Atlantic Wall. Right?
His fortifications along
the coast of France,
they reported back where it was
well fortified, where it wasn't,
so that when we were
planning the d day landings,
we knew that Normandy would be
a better place to invade than a,
than a better fried, better
fortified spotlight Kallai. So again,
that's the quality of the intelligence
that was being produced by these code and
cipher systems. Again, you can see how
many women and how exclusively female,
uh, many of these, many
of these rooms were.
There was also an African American
code breaking unit for the army.
So the u s army was segregated
during World War II.
So was the army civilian
code breaking force. Uh,
but there was a group of African
American codebreakers again,
who had achieved their college
education in a, you know,
despite enormous barriers in
a segregated school system.
And they were working in the codes
and ciphers that the private sector.
So that'll be familiar to you at Google.
Familiar to everybody who does
any kind of transaction online.
Just today as we hope that our financial
transactions are in ciphered after we
make them an encrypted, which is our
modern word for encipherment. Uh,
so two were banks and companies and
encrypting their communications during the
war. And so this force was, um, this,
this group was assigned to the codes and
ciphers or the private sector to make
sure nobody was doing business with
Hitler or doing business with Japanese
companies like Mitsubishi.
So that was very important work as well.
So just quickly,
the navy women,
so the women on that platform graduating
from Galcher and their frilly white
dresses are now working
for the u s navy as,
and they are actually in the u s navy.
So this is another tipping for women
Woodward to seize the creation of the
waves. Women accepted for volunteer
emergency service. Uh, other forces,
other branch of the military will
create female, uh, divisions as well.
And so the navy decides that it wants its
female code breakers to actually be in
uniform and to be subject
to military hierarchy.
So the women are sent back there actually
to send to Smith College to officer's
training camp and they will return to
Washington, uh, as full naval officers.
And also this is a great moment because
women who haven't had the benefit of a
college education can
enlist in the u s navy. Uh,
and if they test high for aptitude,
their math abilities or the language
abilities than they will also be routed
into the code breaking operation.
So ultimately the U s navy,
we'll have 4,000 women working.
This is a facility that is on Nebraska
Avenue in Washington DC. They,
it was also a girl's school. They kicked
the women out, they built barracks,
they moved the female
naval code codebreakers in.
You can see again how female
these code breaking offices are.
And you can see the camaraderie of,
um, of the women working in these, uh,
in these offices.
Uh,
and just a quick anecdote because it's
one of my favorite anecdotes to give you
a sense of what it was like for these
women to come together from all over the
country. Ultimately, one of the
women in my, uh, in my book,
Jane Cased Huddle,
remembers enlisting in the u s navy.
Uh,
and she was actually the daughter
of a very affluent family.
Her Dad was a physicist Theodore case,
and she thought when she enlisted in the
u s navy that she would be made a naval
officer because she came
from such an elite family.
Her family didn't want
her to join the navy.
It was considered somewhat scandalous
for young women to go into the military.
At first,
some people thought they were bad girls,
but she very much wanted
to join the war effort.
And so she took the subway from the upper
east side of Manhattan down to a naval
recruiting station and round Wall Street.
And she knew that going in as an officer,
she would have to take an eye exam
and she was very near sighted. Uh,
and so she had memorize the eye chart
and she slipped her spectacles into her
pocket and she passed the eye exam.
Uh,
but then she had to go around to all of
these other medical stations to sort of
get basically the
equivalent of a physical.
And she got to the place where the women
were told to strip down and disrobe
because men joining the u s navy had
to undergo a group naked physical.
And so the women had to as well.
And so Jane had gone to a very
fancy women's boarding school,
girls school on the upper east side.
She had never seen another woman
without her clothes on. Uh,
the word breast was never uttered a at
her fancy boarding at our fancy school.
Uh,
so she had to take her clothes off and
then a petty officer came up and drew a
number between her breasts,
the number nine and red marker
between her breasts and said,
our now go San between eight
and 10 for your physical.
And Jane was so near sighted that she
not only had to really look at the other
women,
but she had to really get up close and
pier in order to figure out where she was
supposed to stand.
So that was her welcome to the u s navy.
She's never forgotten it.
Uh,
and her other welcome was that she
thought she would go in as an officer,
but the cause she had was a graduate of,
I believe it's called the Longy music
school here actually in the Boston area.
That was not considered by the, the
navy, the equivalent of a college degree.
So she went in as, as what was called an
ordinary seaman as an enlisted woman. Uh,
so she had to actually live
in the barracks along with
all of the other enlisted
women.
And she loved it.
It was the great moment of
her life getting out of sort
of debutante society and
being able to live a alongside and
work alongside women from all over the
country. It was an incredibly
important moment for her. Uh, she,
she recalls working in these,
in these rooms with incredible pride,
which was true of all of these women.
In fact, this is a quote from Jane,
she could,
so we could tell what was happening in
the Pacific because the stack would get
larger.
So you can see the Japanese naval
messages piled up on these women's desks.
They are breaking these naval messages
as fast as they can because they know
that we are pushing back
across the Pacific. Of course,
the ultimate goal is to retake the
Philippines and then possibly attack, uh,
the Japanese mainland.
Uh,
and so the women know that they're
brothers and boyfriends are out there.
In some cases,
they are breaking messages that
foretell the fate of their brothers and
boyfriends ships and they want
to do everything they can.
They have to do a lot of triage to
determine which are the most important
messages and then move them
along as fast as they can.
You can see this is just a worksheet
that I found in the national archives.
You can see that they're working,
that's five digit super enciphered system.
So they're doing the brain work in order
to subtract out the insight from it,
a re reversing the false math but non
carrying edition that's been used there.
They're having to reverse engineer that
in order to get down to the code group
and then tell what that core group stands
for in order to know where the ship is
carrying and where it's going to be a.
And so these are just some worksheets
that I found in the national archives that
show the brainwork and again,
just very briefly,
we will eventually take over the Atlantic
breaking of the enigma cipher from the
British. Uh, so it turned,
so the Germans get suspicious that we
have broken the enigma cipher as we have
add. The German navy makes its
enigma machines more complicated.
It adds a road or there were three
rotors originally to scramble the German
messages.
They add a fourth Roeder.
And so the British machines that Alan
Turing helped design no longer work,
uh, well enough to break those
systems. So we build these faster,
bigger machines at, um, at a,
at a factory in Dayton, Ohio,
there secretly transported to Washington
DC where we take over Atlantic Ocean
code breaking.
And it's pretty much exclusively being
done by women who are designing really
the equivalent of early computer menus.
They're looking at a scrambled German
message. They are conjecturing where,
and that message,
a German phrase like the sky,
a wetter weather in the Bay of Biscay
might appear and then they're doing the
mental brainwork to think, or
what loop would produce, you know,
would turn this letter into this letter
and then this letter until this letter a,
and so they're designing basically
early computer menus that will then be
plugged in those into those machines
to see if they were a plausible, uh,
what's called key setting. Uh,
and then if it is plausible,
they'll plug the message
into a smaller machine.
That's basically the equivalent
of the enigma. It will,
if it produces an actual German messages,
they know they've got it right.
That will be translated by women who will
then take it to the room where another
group of women,
mostly the voucher women are,
are maintaining these huge wall maps,
uh,
showing all of the u
boats and their locations.
They'll write up intelligence reports
for naval headquarters generating
intelligence reports.
And as a result of that,
and of course the work that was being
done in the Atlantic Ocean by submarine
commanders,
we clear the Atlantic Ocean of the u
boats so that we can send the massive
thousands and thousands of convoys ships
necessary to mount the d day invasion
and begin to liberate Europe.
And this group of women actually were
reading the u boat and messages as the
Germans were looking out on the English,
uh,
English Channel on the
morning of June six, 1944.
And they're seeing the allied invasion
as it starts and the women experience the
landing that way. Uh, and so again,
that shows you how crucially important
the women's contribution was to the war
effort, the kind of intelligence that
they were generating that was used by our
military. These are just
some photos of their, um,
their brief free time in Washington.
That's my center character dot.
Behind a pole there.
Uh,
the women were writing letters incessantly
to keep up morale to the man whose
lives they were trying to
save my central character dot.
Would disentangle herself from her college
boyfriend and she was riding at one
point about a half dozen men.
She was more reluctant to
have that go into the book.
Then the fact of her secret code breaking,
she was a little embarrassed that
she was writing so many guys. But um,
but in fact that was really
quite common at the time. Uh,
and then women were sending
a lot of photos as well,
sort of the equivalent of
selfies they were sending, again,
to keep up morale to the amount overseas.
She would make a best friend,
a former school teachers from Bourbon,
Mississippi.
Remember this was top secret work.
The women were told they would be shot if
they told anybody what they were doing.
So, even though both of these women were
working on the Japanese supply ship code
breaking effort, they never
talked about it to each other. Uh,
they didn't even know that they were
part of the same code breaking effort,
but their friendship was so strong
after the war, uh, that they remember,
they remain close friends. You
can see. Dot. In the stripe
shirt. Her husband, the,
the soldier, she was writing Jim
Bruce. Uh, and that's her friend. Um,
uh,
Ruth Weston from Mississippi.
Ruth would go on to work for
the NSA as a mathematician.
So the national security agency is our
descendant agency of our successful World
War II code breaking.
Ruth would work as a mathematician
for NSA until she became pregnant.
And then I found her
handwritten resignation note
from the 1950s I resigned my
position as a mathematician with the NSA
because I'm expected to be home with my
children.
And so after the war,
basically the women were
told in secret letters,
thanks very much for your service. Now get
back, get back home to the kitchen. Uh,
and, and those should them did leave
and go back to private life eventually,
either, either immediately or
eventually when they had children,
they were expected to leave
the workforce again and uh,
but there are friendships remained so
powerfully strong that actually when Ruth
Weston was, um, was engaged to her
husband who you saw in that photo, uh,
she invited dot up to and harassment
basically to vet him that cause she
wouldn't agree to marry him until dot.
Had given the okay.
And this is a group of naval
enlisted women who, um,
remain such close friends after the
war that they had a chain letter going
between their friendship group and that
chain letter kept going for 75 years,
uh, until, until when I was
doing my reporting. The woman
in the front, Ruth Mirsky,
uh, was ultimately the only one of them
left and her emails sign on his roof,
the wave.
So even though she could never talk about
her service and never got credit for
it, uh, anywhere, uh,
her identity as a naval enlisted woman
and as a naval codebreaker remained that
important to her that her email
sign on would be Ruth the wave. Uh,
and so I want to leave time for questions,
so I'm just going to show two videos
that will just let you hear the voices of
the women themselves. Uh, and I
have others that are on my website.
They're actually all on youtube. So,
um, you all can easily enough listen,
listen to the other women as well.
So this is dot.
Talking about her train ride to Washington
with my two suitcases,
my umbrella and my rain coat.
I went down to the train.
Now my uncle had to take me down by no
car and my mother and her sister were
standing there crying
when I got on the train.
I was very secure that everything was
going to be just that Washington would
receive me with open arms.
And of course you're welcome to Washington
was being told that she would be shot
if she disclosed the nature of
the work that she was doing.
And so I just want to finish it like
you hear the voice of Dorothy Ramallah.
You saw her photo earlier
in the presentation. She was
the aspiring math teacher.
She was called in by the Dean of women
at her teacher's college and asked to
take the army's correspondence course
and she gives you the sense of why the
women were so motivated to do this work.
She remember seeing all the men in her
math class rounded up and put on a bus,
uh, you know, to go off
to, to fight and, and, and,
and she recalls sort of
the emotion of that moment.
Oh, bus. Okay. And it was at
two o'clock in the morning
that the aren't arrays Santa
above to get these problem?
I don't know.
It seemed to me it was all
the bad knee in a that,
that there were no men left
in a car at the time, current
date, but they all had to go.
I think that Pittsburgh is the sense I
was taking mathematics at town was I was
one of maybe two girls up or in they cost.
So I knew so many of the
fellows that were going on that
I'm there for you.
And what I also love about Dorothy
Ramallah is it she became a math teacher
after the war at the public middle
school in Arlington, Virginia,
that my own children would later attend.
And so that's an example of how these
women continued to walk among us without
getting any credit for what they did.
And I love the thought of all of these
middle schoolers taking Mr Molly's
Algebra one or Algebra two class and
having no idea that this sweet kind woman
who many of them remembers that Beth
math teacher they ever had had been a
Badass code break during World War II.
She was so good at what she did that the
u s navy poached her from the U s army
by offering an officers'
housing allowance.
So she went from the Japanese supply
ship code to work in the Japanese naval
fleet code. That's how good
she was. Uh, and so, uh,
it has really been the honor of my
career to get to spend time and interview
these women about their work and to try
to get some attention to the work that
they did because it was pioneering a
code breaking hacking and computer work
that they were doing a
cybersecurity cyber intelligence.
This is what they were doing.
And again,
I think of them as the hidden figures
of the greatest generation and their
contribution, uh, was, uh,
was, was remarkable. I mean,
it helped us win the war after the war.
Uh,
the estimates was that that code breaking
shortened the war by at least a year,
probably more and save thousands
of lives on all sides, you know,
access and allied lives because
the war was shortened. Uh,
and so I have time to take
a couple of questions.
If you have time before you
go back to your workplaces,
I'd be happy to field any questions
that you have. Thanks for listening.
[inaudible] given
that their work was secret.
I'm curious,
at what point were they allowed to speak
about it or did you have any trouble
getting them to talk about it? That's
a great question. Thank you for asking.
So the story of Wartime World War
Two Cobra, he'd began to leak out as,
as memoirs and histories
began to be written.
And so at a certain
point in the early 1990s,
the story was officially declassified,
but nobody tracked down the women and
told them that it was okay to talk.
So there were, you know, there were more
than 10,000 women who did this work.
Moshe then carry the
secret to their graves. Uh,
when I was trying to talk dot Braden into
telling me her story and told me about
a half an hour to persuade her that it
was finally okay to talk because nobody
had given them the go ahead. Uh, so, uh,
so that's why they didn't get credit and,
and, but she wanted to tell her
story because after the war,
both of her brothers survived the war
in both of them had top secret security
clearances in their work after the war.
And they would get together and
Brag about their clearances and dot.
Could never tell them that she had a top
secret security clearance as well. Oh.
So that's how it felt frustrating.
It sometimes was,
I assume most of the messages that they
were decoding would be in German or
Japanese or another language.
Were they also then having
to take language training
so they can recognize words
when they came up?
Yeah, that's a great
question. So the, the, the,
the code systems that you saw that were
in, there were a number of groups. Uh,
so let's say it stood for rice.
Let's say the core groups should,
for me to work carrying rice,
you didn't have to necessarily even
think the Japanese word for rice.
You could think the English word
for, right. So some of the systems,
you didn't really have to know much
Japanese and the military, you know,
these supply ships, it, there was
a pretty limited vocabulary, uh,
that the supply ships would be using.
So they could be taught
a little bit of Japanese,
the names of islands and things like
that. And, and work with those, um,
those numerical code systems.
But if it was the enigma machine,
which was scrambling German messages,
or if it was the Japanese purple machine,
which was taking romanized, that's
essentially phonetic spelling of Japanese,
uh, that is then scrambled by the machine.
And then what you get at the end is,
again, phonetically spelled Japanese.
They did need translators. So if, if a,
if a young woman from the seven
sisters had majored in German,
she would be snatched up to work
at the enigma unit. And similarly,
there weren't many people
who knew Japanese, but,
but some people who did were missionaries.
And so graduates of Bible colleges
would actually be improved,
recruited to work as Japanese,
uh, translators. And in fact,
the Japanese surrender message,
the first person who read that was a
young woman who was a graduate of Bethany
College in West Virginia.
She had been a missionary and so
she was being used as a translator.
So she was the first person who
read the Japanese surrender message.
I'm Kevin a spot, my [inaudible]
interested in this subject area.
Why did he start at researchers?
I happen to have a conversation with
a group of historians at the NSA.
All of our,
most of our federal agencies
have wonderful historians
offices like the FBI does,
the CIA does,
NSA does.
And I was speaking to a woman historian
there and a a woman who is a curator at
the, uh, we have a little
cryptography museum in Fort Meade,
Maryland that is our
equivalent of Bletchley Park.
And they told me this story based on
some documents that I had come across a,
I was talking to them and they spent
several hours with me and laid out the
story at a time when I didn't
know anything about code breaking.
I look back at some of the questions
I asked them and sort of my level of
ignorance. This is
embarrassing, but, um, uh,
so the minute I heard the story,
I thought it would be an
incredible story to tell. And,
and is a time period when I hidden figures
had not yet been published. Uh, uh,
there's a great book called rise of
the rocket girls that wasn't out yet.
So there were a number of books
that were percolating along kind of
simultaneously about women's contributions
to the stem field and to American
history. Uh, and so the
minute they told me the story,
I knew that I would like to try to tell
it and I just had to ascertain whether
or not I could find any women who would
be in their mid nineties. Uh, you know,
who could tell me about the work and
whether I could find documentation to
support their recollections.
Because of course I couldn't use their
recollections unless I could document it.
And I was surprised at how I had to
have a lot of records declassified.
It took about a year and a half,
but there was a lot of information
already in the archives at the national
archives hit that had just really been
neglected by historians, I must say,
because the cryptographic museum
now have copies of your book.
I think that that's a good question.
I think it does. Yes, I fit check.
Thank you for asking. So this sounds like
a story that more people need to hear.
Will there be a movie?
It has.
It has been optioned and it's working
its way through that process. So I agree.
I mean that really is how many, you know,
many people come to stories like this,
so thank you.
Scott,
did you find any records in the colleges,
like in all of the seven sisters colleges?
Did they keep their own records about
the women who left during the war?
That's a great question. Oh, I'm sorry.
Women who left during the war
to do this work. Yes, yes.
So Wellesley college in
particular has done a good job,
a really good job of maintaining those
archives. And Galcher has as well.
Some of the other schools really didn't
even necessarily know that it had
happened because very few records were
kept. And the only reason that Wellesley,
one of the reasons is,
is a class of 19,
I'm a member of the class of 1942 decided
to send surveys to all of her female
classmates to find out what they
did during the war. And, and, and,
and the number of them wrote to
say, well, I was a code breaker. Uh,
and this was the first inkling really,
that,
that any of their classmates
had of what they had done.
And I went and looked at those archives.
And it's fascinating though to see what
the other women were doing as well.
You really get a sense of how women were
being suddenly recruited by Armstrong
Cork, uh, by, you know, all
of the defense contractors,
they're all out there reading blueprints
and, and you know, using their math and,
and language educations in so
many different capacities. Uh,
so that was actually,
that was a wonderful trove of documents.
It really gave me a sense of, and the
women themselves, remember they said,
you know,
we had so few recruiters on campus in
1941 and everything changed by 1942
thank you for spending your birthday.